and when did it click for the two of you
that you wanted to also be behind the
camera I know you have girl's gotta eat
productions that's your and you've done
another movie before this together but
when did that click that okay let's
let's do our own projects well that's
that's funny we did Hippocratic oath as
a test run to see if we could do it we
it's a short it's great it's powerful
but you know we have very much a
learning process you know the camera was
fuzzy with the camera guy we hired and
you know we thought oh we'll put this
out and did really well though in terms
of just showing it around as a sample
piece I guess of what we could do with
zeros zero dollars we thought that's it
that's you know no yeah so it was right
around then when we knew we wanted to
make after to give it to write something
to see how we would perform and put all
the obstacles in it had animals kids and
crowds know all the things you're never
supposed to do I'm not supposed to tell
the drama and you're not sorry like
screw it why don't you know let's just
get it over with and so girls Cuddy was
actually just my loan out as an actor I
think you know a lot of us just have
loan out companies so her purposes tax
purposes and whatnot and so it became
our it was like that's a production
company name we're gonna just be able to
do that and after came about when we had
some bites but they wanted to yeah
change this and change this and change
that and Hollywood too much up this look
I get that for dramatic purposes we had
to up the stakes you know you've got to
make it a little on the up the stakes
side but the things they wanted to do
like know we can do better and we can do
this yeah I think I think for us it
became a you know I think more for
Sabrina than myself because I I just got
caught in the wind of this so to speak
you know this was not a unexpected I
didn't start off my life going I'm gonna
be a filmmaker you know this was a
process in which I found myself stepping
up to the challenge
and it was you know
the light that shined was that was it
done so the I think one of the big
things is that the script started as a
healing process for Sabrina and a medium
that she could convey it and sort of
because I never wrote before it was a
diary really yeah and it wasn't
something that we had you know we were
gonna make a film and everything like
that it was something that started as a
healing piece and then it has it started
to build and we started to realize that
this is our story and we need to tell
this story and communicate it out to the
world and of course once you tap into
the creative element right all of a
sudden it's the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing and the next
thing it just spawns I mean Sabrina
wrote this it took years to get it
molded for her and make it feel right
and then she banged out - unbelievable
scripts within a month right after that
you know and I uh I made the mistake of
once we decided we're gonna do this
because for me it was about hitting rock
bottom you know how do I heal myself how
do I get out of my depression and our
level of PTSD from this cuz home for the
whole thing and I needed to do something
that you know went because the only
place is up from rock bottom so what is
that what does that look like how would
my family react if that happened to me
because it was very close that it did
almost was me so mm-hmm
how would they react and I just sort of
built it from there to find that dark
place and only then could I see it
because once you can see something I
think head-on then you can find your way
to heal or fix the only see solution
instead of problem so that was what I
needed to do
to fix myself and then some friends were
like what you're doing this and they
read it and they're like do you know
many people because it isn't just about
that event like I say you know we don't
as survivors corner the market on grief
we don't own that there's a lot of
people that go through this every day
all over the world and it needed to
ultimately be about loss like I couldn't
write about a car accident or a murder
because that wasn't my experience I
could only write about my experience and
what happened
you